new at 11 a local man is making it his
mission to help refugees from Ukraine
Jonathan Strader is working with the All
Hands and Hearts organization to
basically go overseas and help build a
shelter that will house Ukrainian
refugees that fled the war-torn nation
you are looking at video from last April
of refugees crossing the Polish border
Strader tells us he spent most of the
last year trying to figure out a way to
help it's really important just to do
something that binds people together
instead of splitting people apart it
makes me feel better because I know I'm
helping somebody else
straighter will be there for over a
month while the organization is covering
food and accommodations he's trying to
raise money to cover travel costs